is Halloween all right Natty told me
what the two of you did
High Wing's fine I'm keeping an eye on
her she's safe Poppy I promise good
whatever the poachers are up to I want
hiring far from it you said you had news
about the poachers and that some of it
had to do with me it did I overheard
them talking in the hog's head and did
you know that they have orders from
Victor Rookwood to capture you on site
does this have anything to do with
Rookwood and Harlow coming for you in
the three broomsticks after the troll
attack it does somewhat but at the
moment I'm more concerned about what
else you heard the poachers are up to
fair enough
but I hope you'll let me know if I can
be of help especially after what you did
for high Wing does the name horntail
Hall mean anything to you I'm afraid not
why what is it the poacher's best kept
secret apparently
the name came up twice but they never
went into detail I also overheard one of
them bragging about all the gold they're
making at the expense of innocent
creatures undoubtedly the poachers spoke
of this area and I thought if we
searched around a bit it might give us
Clues as to what they're doing if you
ever meet my gran this trip never
happened
not to worry poppy if I ever meet your
Gran I shall not speak a word of this I
normally tell her everything she might
be my best friend after hiring but she
knows how I feel about the poachers
she worries I'll do something
ill-advised whatever gave her that idea
tread carefully
an entire Castle to Rome yet you choose
to wander here
please we don't want any trouble we're
simply passing through
do you take us for fools that we do not
notice more and more of your kind around
here in League with the poachers
we aren't involved with them if anything
we want to see them stopped
I hope for your sake that is true Our
Kind is swiftly losing patience with the
poachers and those they work with
he was certainly a charmer
they've gone worse Santos aren't exactly
fans of wizard kind and the poachers
aren't helping matters
but why would he think that we had
anything to do with poachers
I did notice the poachers talking with a
few villagers in hogsmead I'm not sure
why
perhaps that's why the centaurs are
suspicious
third time I've seen a dug bug behave
that violently
it seems that a lot of beasts have been
more aggressive than usual lately I've
noticed that too it's almost like
there's something in the water
[Music]
foreign
what is it not entirely sure but look
around if the poachers were here perhaps
we can find out why
[Music]
revelio
good
why wouldn't they take their cages with
them when they left
pelt
poor beasts
still smoking
they can't have been gone long
Rebellion
[Music]
this is Goblin metal
seems out of place in a poacher camp
I should tell poppy about it
anything interesting
poachers were here all sorts of evidence
but I found something else it's Goblin
made I found Goblin armor let's keep
searching but carefully
Merlin only knows what's going on here
I don't have a good feeling about this
how do Goblin and poacher interests
align
look down there definitely poachers
no creatures though so what are they
doing out here let's take a closer look
they won't be happy to see us should we
use disillusionment or perhaps a less
discreet approach hard to say from up
here
let's get a better layover land
s I'll Scout around felcroft for
something to poach
it's all about having a Keen Eye
my eyes is clean as a nipples on a pile
of gold or a nocktail to a cell huh I'm
not bragging that's just the two phase
foreign
thank you
ravennial
s
our centaurs quieter than you
foreign
you'd think they were guarding the
minister for magic himself what is going
on here only one way to find out
revelia
foreign
fighting ring
this is hauntel Hall the
Moon secrecy no wonder the poachers were
in hogsmeade so much likely taking bets
and spreading the words given how
crowded it is here how could they
possibly enjoy this the centers have
every right to be disgusted with wizard
kind there must be more dragons here the
poachers are far too greedy to run a
fighting ring with only two dragons we
should take advantage of most guys being
in the fight and look around
be discreet you especially can't afford
to be spotted
what Victor was sinking strong in a
bargain with them
I know you're there
[Applause]
have you heard from your family is even
if your brothers come around to our way
of thinking will you join us ah they say
we go too far the violence is gonna get
us what we want to I say if every last
wizard is run through with a blade then
violence is going to get me precisely
what I want
sickens me to work alongside any of them
don't know how ramrock stomach's been
near awkward found Beast not much longer
now
soon our next will be out from under
Wizarding boots
wizard kind will pay for what they've
done
[Applause]
[Music]
Revenue
[Applause]
foreign
what's going on down there
stuff only just captured her she's
putting up quite the fight
a fair one though not without chained up
like that let's even hurt shall we
ravennial
s
look they've got a dragon egg Rebellion
from the looks of it
can't leave it here not with the plans
they likely have for it
alohomorrah
all right I have the egg
ready the element of surprise will only
buy us a few seconds
let's make them count
attack
there you go
[Music]
foreign
let's get it
back
today
[Music]
vegetables
cookie
oh
kill me
up
Rebellion
this may have been a bad idea I suppose
we'll find out
cool
[Music]
in San Diego
this way
[Music]
that was a hebridian black I'm guessing
the egg we have belongs to that dragon
I don't think she knew they had her egg
she wouldn't have left without it what
now
she didn't exactly leave us a calling
card I I don't know
nothing about this day was expected not
the goblins and definitely not the
fighting ring the last thing I planned
on was a dragon egg and the poachers saw
us which cannot be good
since the dragon we freeze flew off does
that mean we get to keep the egg I'd
much rather we have it than the poachers
at least for now but I don't think we
should keep it indefinitely it'll be
hard hiding something like this from
Professor Weasley for long
not helping ourselves standing here
let's get to safe
we can sort this out later you're right
if there's anything that poachers are
good at it's tracking their prey and
right now we're it
be careful won't you I shall see you
back at the castle